Recall that the Scale problem arises because we have tens of thousands of
servers on a flat layer two Topology, where all of the servers have a Topology
independent MAC or hardware address and thus,
in the default case. Every switch in
the topology has to store affording table
entry for every single MAC address. One solution
is to introduce what are called pods and assign sudo MAC addresses to each
server corresponding to the pod in which
they're location in the Topology. So in addition
to having a real MAC address. Each server has what's known as a pseudo-MAC
address, as shown in pink. Thus, switches
in the Data Centre Topology no longer need
to maintain forwarding table entries for every
host. They only need to maintain entries
for reaching other pods in the Topology. Once a frame answers a pod, the switch
then of course has entries for all of the servers inside that pod but they don't
need to maintain entries for the MAC addresses for servers outside of each pod.
For example, the switch in pod one only
needs to maintain entries for these two servers
with MAC addresses A and B, but it
doesn't need to maintain independent entries with servers
with MAC addresses C and D. It only needs to maintain an entry for how to reach
pod 2. Likewise for pods 2 and pods 3. Now, in such a Data Centre Topology,
of course, these hosts are unmodified. So, their
still going to respond to things like ARP queries,
with their real MAC addresses, so we need a way of dealing with that, as well as
a way of Mapping pseudo MAC addresses to
real MAC addresses. The solution is as follows. When
a host such as server A issues an
ARP query, that query is intercepted by the switch,
but instead of flooding that query, the switch intercepts the query and forwards
it to an entity called the Fabric Manager. The Fabric Manager then responds with
the pseudo-MAC corresponding to that IP address. Host A then sends the frame
with the destination pseudo-MAC address and switches
in the Topology can forward that frame
to the appropriate pod. Corresponding to the pseudo
MAC address of the destination server. Once the
frame reaches the destination pod, let's say in
this case pod 3, the switch at the
top of that pod can then Map the pseudo MAC address back to the real MAC
address. And the server that receives the frame
receives an Ethernet frame with its real destination
MAC address, so it knows that the Ethernet frame was intended for it.
By intercepting our queries in this
way and providing a Mapping between topological
pseudo MAC addresses and real, physical
MAC addresses, we can achieve hierachial forwarding.
In a large Layer 2 Topology, without having to modify any host Software.